they always say female has to stay home
taking care family work nice job and you
don't fight like your men and you know
if you train and fight like that you
will be having big muscle like a man so
you don't look pretty as a girl I had to
fight you know
fight fight with my relative and my
family they always want me to stop
when I always get under ring my mom
always get worried and sometimes she
cried and I got the punch seriously from
the fight you know I always say it on
Facebook like I'm a Cambodian Power Girl
because you know it show a lot of power
and not many girls can do it want more
download the AJ plus mobile app and join
the conversation available in your App
Store now